Google Cloud updates it feels like
everything in cloud is changing all the
time and it's happening so fast so if
you're overwhelmed or even getting to
that point check out this post that
details the latest in products events
and even content from Google Cloud the
appropriately named overwhelmed Person's
Guide to Google Cloud updated weekly via
email and as we close out cyber security
awareness month we shared our progress
across a number of security efforts and
announced a few new technolog IES that
help us keep more people safe online
including developments with and
Frameworks for AI which has the
potential to vastly improve how we
identify address and reduce cyber
security risks and you can find all of
that on the blog and we'll see you next
week for more